hallo deutsch schule training
buchstabieren
deutschland
deutschland2011
sich millionen menschen
in deutschland leben
83 millionen menschen
die hauptstadt von deutschland
ist berlin
wo wohnst du
vogel
vgl
der vogel
der vogel fliegt durch die luft
viele vögel fliegen im winter nach süden
mülleimer
mmr
mülleimer der mülleimer in jedem park
gibt es mindestens einen
mülleimer in jedem park gibt
es mindestens einen mülleimer ich bringe
meinen müll zur mülltonne ich bringe
meinen müll zur mülltonne
armbanduhr
mbh
dkr
armbanduhr die
armbanduhr
meine armbanduhr
ist eine smart watch meine armbanduhr
ist eine smart watch mit meiner
armbanduhr kann ich sogar mein puls
messen mit meiner armbanduhr kann ich
sogar mein puls messen
trägst du eigentlich eine armbanduhr
rucksack
rck
sck
rucksack der
rucksack der rote rucksack der rote
rucksack
jonathan geht mit seinem neuen rucksack
in die schule
flugzeug
ngz
u
g
schlug zeug das flugzeug das flugzeug
fliegt in einer höhe von
10.000 metern
das flugzeug fliegt in einer höhe von
das flugzeug fliegt mit einer
geschwindigkeit von
900 kilometern pro stunde das flugzeug
fliegt mit einer geschwindigkeit von 900
kilometern pro stunde
mikrowelle
mkr
hwg
mikrowelle die
mikrowelle das essen in der mikrowelle
aufwärmen
das essen in der mikrowelle
heute mache ich mir einen leckeren hot
dog in der mikrowelle
was ist dein lieblingsessen
blumenstrauß
bmn
str
sz
blumenstrauß der blumenstrauß ein
blumenstrauß mit
roten rosen ein
blumenstrauß mit acht roten rosen als
zeichen meiner liebe schenke ich dir
heute
diesen
blumenstrauß als zeichen meiner liebe
schenke ich dir heute
diesen
blumenstrauß
kinderwagen
knd
lwg
nrw
der
kinderwagen
das baby liegt im kinderwagen
das baby liegt im kinderwagen die mutter
schiebt den kinderwagen
durch die stadt die mutter schiebt den
kinderwagen
durch die stadt
kaffeemaschine
kfm
schn
kaffeemaschine die
kaffeemaschine kocht kaffee die
kaffeemaschine kocht kaffee in der
frühstückspause
trinke ich heute eine heiße tasse kaffee
in der frühstückspause
trinkst du kaffee oder tee
staubsauger
stb
sgr
stopps auge der staubsauger
der staubsauger saugt staub der
staubsauger saugt staub
heute sage ich meine wohnung mit dem
staubsauger
werde mitglied der halo deutsche schule
und unterstütze uns mit einem kleinen
betrag
so hast du viele vorteile und wir können
weiterhin jeden tag unser bestes für
dich geben
klicke jetzt auf den mitglied werden
button flaschenöffner
aschaffenburg24
de mission öffner die flasche öffnen mit
dem flaschenöffner
wo ist bloß mein flaschenöffner
geblieben wo ist bloß meinen
flaschenöffner
geblieben
er lag auf dem sofa
ventilator
vgt
ltr
ventilator der
ventilator der ventilator macht kühlen
luft in einem raum der ventilator macht
kühle luft in einem raum
ich liebe den ventilator in meinem büro
ich liebe den ventilator
in meinem büro
geburtstagstorte
gmbh
ttg
torc1
torc2
[Musik]
geburtstagstorte auf der
geburtstagstorte ist eine kerze auf
der
geburtstagstorte ist eine kerze
sandra hat von ihren kollegen eine
geburtstagstorte bekommen
geburtstagstorte bekommen wann hast du
geburtstag
toastbrot
tsc
brt
toastbrot das toastbrot
das toastbrot mit dem toaster toasten
zum frühstück esse ich ein leckeres
toastbrot zum frühstück esse ich ein
leckeres toastbrot
waschbecken
w a s
chb
ckm
waschbecken das
waschbecken
in jedem badezimmer
gibt es auch ein waschbecken in jedem
badezimmer
gibt es auch ein waschbecken
ich wasche mir die hände im waschbecken
dusche
[Musik]
duschkab24
mir die haare
nach dem duschen föhne ich mir die haare
die deutschen duschen im durchschnitt
sechs minuten die deutschen duschen im
durchschnitt sechs minuten
badewanne
bdgw
nnp
badewanne die
badewanne in eine badewanne passen
150 liter wasser in eine badewanne
passen
150 liter wasser
heute nehme ich ein bad in meiner
badewanne
hast du auch eine badewanne
hast du gewusst
du kannst auch mitglied der halo deutsch
schule werden
es gibt viele vorteile
auf unserer kanalseite kannst du dich
ein schreiben
werde online schüler der halo deutsche
schule
abonniere jetzt den kanal der halle
deutsch schule und aktiviere das kleine
glöckchen
gib uns jetzt ein daumen nach oben
und klicke auf diese playlist für
weitere videos zum deutsch lernen